Jumanji is a it's a terrific film very
funny film you've got this amazing casts
one of your co-stars is mr. Nick Jonas
yeah and you collaborated on a song with
Nick Jonas - yeah great musical Minds
coming together how did that work out
it's just something we were messing
around with on the set
we're like can you imagine if we came up
with a rad like Jumanji theme song that
would be kind of epic so we did it and
they did not want to use it in the movie
but we went ahead and recorded it you've
recorded it anyway you just recorded it
anyway for shiggles as we like is this
true how does this song go is it
possible that I'm still out of breath
from that entrance here we go yeah yeah
[Music]
oh wait a second I'm gonna sing it but
I'm when I point to you you have to
whisper
okay I do it into this right here yeah
it's not gonna happen for a while okay
I'm gonna change the key to Jumanji it's
the jungle inside your soul somewhere
deep inside at the end of the world
[Music]
Jumma hungie and survival your only GU
plunge the jewel inside say the name of
the game
[Applause]
I think I should have stopped it perfect
no second-guessing too much I those
producers are idiots
yeah should I end the movie would have
opened with that and closed yeah yeah
well the movie has not been released yet
there's still time yes sirs if you want
to stick it in the seconds long in the
credits
yeah yeah excited about this there's
still time
it's Thursday you can still do it DVD
extra and leaf
you